[Music]
did you put that tape yeah I put that
like two hours of your dismissed
oh my god ad work you see how much more
tape you can get I wonder if we can
spell something how are you doing Newman
part of no print I know I ripped it
ripped up my shirt that was too damn it
too easy
that was that was pathetic ah PC load
letter the is that this thing is
always breaking I'm to print something
for two days and for some reason it
won't it will no longer connect to the
computer and whenever it prints it
prints out those black lines once the
printer gets to the point where it costs
more to fix than to just replace there's
only one thing to do
[Music]
you know we're the landing joining the
ocean item like this is happening right
now we're about to watch the world's
first rocket that has already gone in
outer space and landed be fired again
and landed again
so the spaceship that was going on with
outer space is about to land right here
on the football sides or DeBarge this is
the one that they plan to do on ladrones
last year they said the last year kind
of just refurbishing it and now they
launched it again the world's first
rocket to be launched again and it's
successful but the real question is can
they land it again so it could explode
right now it could it could just hit the
group hit the bars really hard to
explode without it may not mix the rock
everyone's clapping well why are they
clapping I don't know man
get excited they totally have more video
see ya I mean I have corridor gadget HP
color laserjet I'm not sponsored at all
literally doesn't use a new printer but
Wi-Fi you can color one copies okay I
can do black and white color
double-sided anytime you can go under
your phone and there's an option to
print to connect with the same Wi-Fi
signal it'll find that printer and print
it straight out of that app I just can't
find it I've never done that before
it looks like we may not have I can use
video feed from the drone ship right now
oh we off feed straight apostasy but get
it land
nothing is going to sleep boy this thing
is so big - how big is good
they're like platforms the size of a
football field a person could easily
walk underneath that cute if it is huge
did you say I've waked cool for itself
it was a big step for Humanity like no
joke we can reuse Rockets now what
SpaceX has been trying to do for years
they finally did it improve this you
guys everyone shut up you want money
okay the first three flight of an
overpass booster this petition perfectly
couples the second stage came back and
landed on the drone ship right in the
Bulls line two remaining day I think for
space as a whole for the space industry
it means you can you can fly and reef
lie an orbit class booster which is the
most expensive part of the rocket this
is going to be ultimately a huge
revolution in spaceflight it's the
difference between if you had airplanes
where you you threw away an airplane
after every flight versus you could
reuse them multiple times it's been 15
years and proving that something can be
done that many people said was
impossible
thank you you hashtag biofilm deal on a
cake monster rocky comes down and lands
right on the center of the Hebrew food I
know you're doing some ways they're like
are you serious
helping your foot and it spells out I've
been pranked all day what's the rules
cubby what did you get me into
I remember that I remember all camera by
the way ever I was like that was weird
why did you uh
but then you saw her at something on my
hand when I walked away and you
second-guessed it
[Music]
this is war
the second in the third was the best
yeah what were those what happened did
you get those on camera at least is that
what he had the camera just set up over
there staring at me
was it on and rolling that whole time
moment where I looked over and I noticed
that I was like you should have this is
my shirt but who said that the most next
everytime he asked you that question
that was the distraction so if you
actually want to watch the all the
angles from this landing click right
here and you can watch it with us so
it's seven minutes and five seconds and
deploy so we're going to go back down to
the floor as we get ready for the
landing of the first stage in the orbit
of the second stage